climate change is now happening so fast
that leaving oil in the ground is no
longer enough
a new assessment by scientists working
for the united nations shows we need to
halve our greenhouse gas emissions in
just eight years but we also need to
find some way of removing carbon dioxide
from the atmosphere to undo the damage
of the past
we are on a fast track to climate
disaster
it is underwater unprecedented it waves
terrifying storms widespread water
shortages the extinction of a million
species of plants and animals
and these is not fiction or exaggeration
it is what science tells us will result
from our current energy policies
nature can be our ally according to the
intergovernmental panel on climate
change steered marshes in somerset cover
just one square mile but they remove and
store almost 18 000 tons of carbon
dioxide from the atmosphere every year
scale that up plant trees stop peat bogs
being drained and rewilding could buy us
time
it can happen relatively quickly we know
how to do it
it takes time steer you know took eight
years or so but in the grand scheme of
things that's that's not a long time and
if we
unlock these sorts of solutions at scale
we can do this within the next five to
ten years and buy ourselves that time to
bring the technologies on stream in the
longer term to reduce our emissions
further
the first attempts are being made to use
technology to suck carbon dioxide out of
the air and store it underground it's
expensive and inefficient for now but
the un scientists say without it there
is little hope of raining in the rapid
rise in global temperatures
the glasgow climate conference was just
a small step in the right direction
pledges to cut emissions are not the
same as action and at the moment the
world is still on course for three
degrees of warming
the report is scathing about our
continued use of fossil fuels coal in
particular it calls for an even more
rapid shift to renewables more energy
efficient housing and a rethink of how
we design cities so people need to drive
less
one of the scientists says it can be
done
if we
act
now
if we act rapidly if we make the big
transformational changes that are
necessary
there's still a glimmer of hope of
getting to 1.5 and if we miss 1.5
we still stopped it going
1.6 1.7 1.8 so whatever effort we put in
will save lives
the report was delayed by two days as
195 governments wrangled over the text
the un chief has accused them of lying
over their past climate commitments and
scientists are clear on the urgent need
for action it's now or never thomas more
sky news